[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts
the sorting hat the house system and
some of the muggle characters
from the series more specifically i'm
going to be assigning
the unassigned placing vernon and
petunia desley
into the hogwarts houses that i see fit
in a previous
standalone video i sorted dudley so if
you haven't seen that then go and check
it out
but today i'm going to be discussing his
parents
now sorting occurs at the sorting
ceremony
an annual tradition at hogwarts that
falls at the beginning of the school
year
the function of the ceremony is to
assign new students
to one of the four houses gryffindor
hufflepuff
ravenclaw or slytherin students are
sorted using the sorting hat
a sentient hat that once belonged to
hogwarts founder
godric gryffindor recognizing that they
each valued very different traits in
students
hence the rationale for having four
houses in the first place
each founder passed on the main criteria
for their particular house
to the hat the student then places the
hat on their head
and is assigned to a house based on
which founder they resemble most
to perform its task the hat uses
legitimacy
which is the art of magically navigating
through a person's mind
the hat will navigate the layers of the
wearer's mind and
after careful consideration announce its
decision loudly
so that all can hear if the hat senses
great bravery gryffindor is a likely
choice
if the hat senses great intelligence
ravenclaw is a likely choice
if the hat senses that someone is a hard
worker hufflepuff
is a likely choice and finally if the
hat senses that someone is hungry for
power
then slytherin is a likely choice
something to bear in mind
however is that just because someone is
sorted into for example
gryffindor proving their bravery it
doesn't mean that they aren't
hardworking
ambitious or clever it just means that
their bravery
is perhaps a slightly overarching
character trait
this type of logic applies to all of the
other houses
as well without further ado let's dive
in to the sorting of vernon and petunia
dursley
when harry's parents were murdered on
october 31st 1981
the decision was made that harry would
be raised by his aunt petunia
and her family part of the reasoning for
this was that harry would remain
protected
by his mother's loving sacrifice so long
as he could so-called the dursley
resident's
home furthermore the life of fame and
fortune that harry was destined to have
may not have been a good start to the
young boy's life
so where did he go instead a place where
he couldn't have been treated any less
famous
the dursley residents the dursley family
was comprised of vernon
the father petunia the mother and dudley
the son though they hated any and all
things magical
and were perhaps the antithesis of the
sort of family that should adopt harry
they were the safest option however
while harry was certainly
safe from the dursleys at least from a
physical standpoint
it was not a good environment to grow up
in they were always
massively critical of harry and
certainly didn't like anything that was
out of the ordinary
a tall order when you've adopted a
magical young boy they showed a blatant
favoritism toward their actual son
dudley forced harry to live in a
cupboard under the stairs
tried to prevent him from attending
hogwarts and always hid his past from
him
so to which house do these monsters
belong
vernon desley was an english muggleborn
and arguably
harry's biggest tormentor he was head
honcho in the dursley household
and worked an office job for a company
called grunnings in london
he was a very safe individual and didn't
like anything out of the ordinary
he had very predictable unique
perspectives on the world
and had a strong aversion disliking of
anything that contradicted
his own world view so where would i sort
vernon
he wasn't brave not in the slightest and
this immediately removes gryffindor from
the equation
as you've at least got to be somewhat
brave to be in gryffindor house
he certainly wasn't an intellectual nor
was he particularly
studious and i think that this also
eliminates ravenclaw as a potential
option
this leaves hufflepuff and slytherin
hufflepuff could work for him
and i say this purely because he's a
hard worker but i think that the safest
bet is slytherin
slytherin house is responsible for
producing the most evil
wizards and from this i can reasonably
derive that they have the least
tolerance when it comes to other world
views
this sounds just like vernon furthermore
one of the most important traits for
slytherin
is ambition something that vernon had a
lot of
his quirks aside he was a very driven
career man
and wanted to do whatever it took to get
to the top
furthermore while aspirations of getting
to the top can often indicate that
someone is a hard worker
like a hufflepuff i'm of the impression
that vernon would take whatever
shortcuts he could
which makes him more of a slytherin this
brings us to petunia
petunia dursley born petunia evans was
the sole surviving blood relative of
harry potter
and the sister to harry's mother lily in
spite of this
she was unusually cruel to harry when he
was growing up
and treated him the same way that vernon
did despite her obvious despicable
nature
the cold-hearted evil petunia that were
introduced to in the books and films
wasn't always so bad in fact near at the
beginning of her childhood
she was actually just a normal young
girl that got along with her sister
the same sister that she would later
despise lily's magical accomplishments
started off quite small and though
petunia didn't think much of them at
first
she eventually began to feel the onset
of jealousy
as lily's magic grew stronger she
received a considerable amount of
attention from her parents
for her gifts and i think that petunia
who had none
just felt left out though petunia was
jealous at this stage
she didn't yet hate her sister in 1971
lily received her letter to hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
it was a momentous occasion for the
family most of them anyway
the youngest daughter of the evans
family was a witch
when petunia saw lily receive her letter
she felt a rush of emotions
confusion anger but most of all jealousy
and despite not being magical she felt
compelled to write a letter to
dumbledore
himself asking to attend at the school
hoping to be a part of the magical
school herself
petunia stated her case at dumbledore
and asked if she could study there with
her sister
however given that petunia was not
magical in any way
dumbledore had to politely decline
petunia's request to attend the school
from that day onward petunia denounced
magic entirely
it was a world that rejected her and the
pain that she felt from her rejection
manifested itself in the form of anger
toward her sister
whom she would now refer to as a freak
unfortunately it turned her into
a very bitter dark person but i do think
that
deep deep down there was an element of
good to petunia
however this certainly doesn't excuse
any of the horrific behavior
that she has exhibited petunia is
perhaps the hardest person to sort
ever as it's certainly not as simple as
she did bad things
therefore she is in southern petunia was
a complex character with many layers
and had she not been rejected by the
wizarding world as a girl
could have turned out to be very
different she doesn't really have one
characteristic
that meshes exceedingly well with any
one house though i do have an argument
for why i feel that she is oddly enough
a gryffindor when harry potter was left
on her doorstep after lily and james
potter had been murdered
with only a note explaining what had
happened she must have felt a surge of
emotions
first of all this was the first time she
had been informed
that her own sister was dead petunia and
nearly didn't get along for the majority
of their lives
but there was a time when they were
children that they would proudly declare
their sisterhood
petunia's biggest fault as a person was
that she allowed her rejection
from the magical world to transform her
into a bitter
cruel person however i don't think she
ever wanted to be that person
she just lacked the strength of
character to deal with her own
circumstances
her main problem was just that she was
weak and i think that
in the moment she realized her own
sister was dead she showed a
considerable amount of courage
by taking in harry not only was this boy
a constant reminder of the world
that had rejected her it was also a
constant reminder of her dead sister
the sister that she never got to make
amends with facing the situation
day in and day out would have been
exceedingly difficult
and though she didn't do it graciously
she still opted to raise harry
and to keep him safe as for dudley go
and check out the link in the
description
what do you guys think where would you
sort vernon and petunia dursley
i'd love to hear what you guys have to
say on this matter
comment down below if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel
you're a wizard harry
you